if i make it back tomorrow night and get
the fifth bible study it'll be a super
miracle from god you make it sound like
it's a matter of life and death
that's exactly what it is
if you could take a peek into a secret
society
what would you see
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness hey everybody
welcome back to led live today we have
an exciting show and i know we say that
a lot on this show but today you're not
gonna want to miss this show because we
have an amazing guest chris lang
thank you for joining us he has produced
quite a number of films here um that is
a very very fascinating topic
about a guy who spent time in a secret
society i mean got really
deep in that secret society and uh
you're gonna you're gonna want to hear
this story because he's made a couple of
films now centering around um this
person roger morneau's life and if he's
roger morneau has has written a book
uh
you tell us a little bit about this
yeah for those who don't know about
roger morneau uh roger mourinho was a
demon worshiper
who became a christian author and prayer
warrior man
there were
19 year old couple cyril and cynthia
gross who
met cyril the husband met roger at a
factory one day and
somehow
roger became curious to find out about
his beliefs and they ended up studying
the bible together and not only was
roger attacked by the spiritual realm
but also cyril and cynthia also
experienced a very real spiritual force
that was trying to destroy them for
studying the bible that's something i
talk about a lot you know like satan is
not trying to attack the world you know
the
you would think because they're messing
around with stuff that get attacked more
but really as long as they're drinking
and partying he just sits back and
watches them you know
self-destruct it's when you make a
decision like
i want to know the bible man be ready
for war spiritual warfare satan is
coming after you yeah and from what i
understand out of roger mourinho's story
what's amazing about it is that it
wasn't just being courted
spiritually he was being quarterly
physically in this in the physical realm
he was actually has people approach him
and say we want you a part of our team
and here's what our team does and you'll
receive special gifts for this that
wasn't a fascinating part of this whole
thing
we would like to thank all of you who
support this ministry through your
donations and by buying merch from
lightwear.shop
we cannot do this without you and if you
send in your pictures we will put you on
the show
yeah you know
as a filmmaker
and producing
what is truth based as best as you can
i started working with roger's family
roger passed away by the way in 1998. he
wrote six books and um his first book is
his conversion story originally titled a
trip into the supernatural i read that
book amazing posters multiple times it's
like re-re-listen re-watch whatever it's
just it's a great story it's very well
known uh both inside the seventh-day
adventist church and outside people who
aren't even christian or fascinated by
his testimony
but many people have questioned his
story and so as a filmmaker when i when
i got permission to work with roger's
daughter who is responsible for his
legacy
um my concern was lord help us prove the
things that we can prove in order to add
credibility to the things we can't prove
one of the things when you read roger's
book
is he doesn't mention specific names in
the secret society
most likely to protect his family
and he never revealed these specific
locations in montreal but he gave enough
detail
so that i was able to in my research
find out
um historical places in montreal
that
were very credible based on the way he
described where this mansion was where
this secret group met
but in addition to that so
i didn't want to spend time speculating
in the film about things that we didn't
have witnesses
and so um i said lord please help us and
so
i have seen you can anyone who's
watching today can google roger
mourinho's name and find
people making posts that they don't
believe his story because of x y and z
they'll say things like roger was not
born in a roman catholic family they'll
say roger was never in the merchant navy
in world war ii he was never in the army
there's no evidence of that well guess
what god did
over a period of six years it took years
to put this film together and by the way
one film ended up being coming three
yeah
that was not the play
charm by darkness is actually the
project that presents his life story
and while i was working on this with the
family god opened the doors with
research in canada because roger was
french canadian
we found documents in the roman catholic
church that proved that he was born
and baptized there as you know they
christen babies
and the catholic church is very good at
documenting historical uh uh events like
that as well as as
going through the next phase in a young
boy's life where they actually are able
to take communion both of those
documents were found and you'll see them
in the film wow you also see documents
from world war ii now just a little
tidbit for people
in canada they don't have world war ii
war documents digitized
and for researchers who are riding on
that era in canadian history you can't
just walk into a library or museum and
go hey give me a file on roger morneau
no that's why no one has ever seen this
before but you'll see it in the film
awesome i talked to 10 researchers you
guys
and nine of them up over a period of two
years either didn't know what they were
talking about or were too busy or not
interested because it was a christian
film
with christian worldview et cetera but
when the tenth one came along
it's a fascinating story because
um he he was he's a phd researcher he
had written several books on world war
ii
and amazingly
in 30 seconds while i was listening to
him i could tell he knew what he was
talking about
you can't just walk in there in fact
they're not only not digitized they're
in they're in boxes in a warehouse
physical files wow and you you
you have to know the name of one of the
ships the person worked on and there
were 12 000 12 000 canadian
civilians who worked on ships they were
called merchant navy seaman
rogers says that he worked for three
years well fortunately
in this book that we came out with in
2015 which is his full manuscript he
mentions the name of one of the ships he
worked on
i get it to the researcher and he ended
up finding a file that
in the the folder with the ship's name
you have to then search through it and
find a contract that that ship had with
an individual civilian oh wow and they
actually this researcher went through
all these boxes until he landed on one
that had roger's name he was 19 years
old
and you see that in our film
it was a miracle but here's a greater
miracle this man this tenth researcher
this phd
professor up in canada and ontario and
ottawa the capital city
while i was talking to him asking him to
do this research for us
he asked me what it was about so i gave
him the 20-second elevator speech
it's about roger morneau a demon
worshiper who became a christian author
and prayer warrior
and there was a pregnant silence on the
phone and then a very defensive tone of
his voice he
said oh so this is a christian film
and i said well it does deal with
christian principles and he said
but
but i happened to be a jew from the
bronx
and i said why
that's his name is nathan well nathan
that is very interesting
roger marnell actually ended up studying
about the biblical sabbath and he became
a sabbath keeper also wow
so we have that in common roger has that
in common with you wow
then he was quiet for a minute and he
said
but i happen to be a card-carrying
atheist who is a jew from the bronx
and remember this is the tenth
researcher over a two year period trying
to find proof
documented proof that roger was telling
the truth about his story wow and so i
sent up a prayer lord
this is your story right it's kind of
like in the bible when um nehemiah in
the book of nehemiah it says and i
prayed to the lord and i said to the
king
it's like it was an instant prayer
nehemiah and that was kind of what
happened there in that space wow and
suddenly um
this man nathan he goes
well
i guess because you're asking me only to
do research relating to the war records
and not relating to christianity
i suppose i can help you
and then he proceeded to cut his fee in
half oh wow
which made it affordable for wow and so
so
but here's the rest of the story i think
that even actually adds credibility to
your story that there's a guy that like
he's not
drumming up this information to try to
promote yeah you know what i mean like i
think that's how god works sometimes
right he is the most unlikely guy so
that you can't be like oh yeah they just
made this up by talking to this guy and
this guy no this guy doesn't want this
story to be told that's a good point
it's not an infomercial for a particular
worldview we wanted to tell the facts as
much as god would help us find okay and
so the rest of the story guys is that
nathan called me a week later the day
before he told me he was going to go
into the library and start sorting
through boxes
he said chris i just wanted to call you
i'm not going to be able to go tomorrow
because my mother just had a major heart
attack in the bronx my wife and i have
to get ready and fly to the bronx
tomorrow to check on her the day before
he was supposed to go
and for the next 30 minutes he asked me
question after question after question
after question about this young roger
morneau who
left his childhood faith
and ended up in demon worship in a
secret society and after 30 minutes the
reason i know it was 30 minutes is
because i was looking at my watch where
would you be concerned about if your mom
just had it yeah right yeah i'd be on
the plane
in the car finally i started feeling
guilty and i said nathan listen i know
you got to go buddy you got to get ready
to go i said but listen
i said when you find that document
because remember we hadn't found the end
of the story had not been told yet but i
said when you find the document i said
nathan i believe you're going to find
proof when you come back
i said i would be happy to send you a
copy of roger's
autobiography
when you find that document that we're
looking for wow i said i bet you would
be curious to read it by the time you
get back and find that and he and he was
quiet for a minute and remember a phd
researcher yeah jewish atheist writer
wow he said to me
i'd like to read that wow
silent yeah teachable moment when people
are in crisis yeah by the way as a
christian when someone's in a crisis
what's the first thing that you want to
say to them i pray for you yeah
i couldn't help myself i thought i might
burn a bridge yeah
but i told him i was going to pray for
him and he was quiet and he said thank
you i would appreciate that yeah you
know what i mean the heart is open at
that point
so so he so when he got back the end of
the story of course he went to the
library they know him by name in this
government library because he's written
multiple books on this topic of this era
in history
and
he
he texted me pictures of the documents
that he found three hours later and he
called me on a cell phone from the
library shouting out of joy like a kid
in a candy store
and he was talking so loudly that the
librarians who knew him by name had to
tell him to be quiet
wow that is amazing
did you hear from him
after he read the book
i have not okay i have not but imagine
the testimonies in heaven man yeah you
know i i wanna i wanna reach out to him
i've been praying for the right time to
reach out so i have a question kind of
going
back back back back back
and you'll probably get to this but
this gentleman that roger met in the
factory his name was cyril cyril yeah
what
made roger
want to ask him
questions like there's probably
a lot of people that work at the factory
right what's what is it about cyril that
roger decides
i want to talk to this guy of all people
yeah that's a great story keith you know
uh
actually it was his jewish boss
uh and and this is another historical uh
fact uh in montreal during the 40s
the vast majority of
garment manufacturing which was a
dominant industry in montreal in the 40s
by the way so again there's historical
precedent for this story that they're
talking about men worked in dress
factories which seemed weird to a 21st
century man was that why would a guy
work in a stitching thing embroidery
shop well back then that was high tech
and you earned a lot of money if you
were artistic
and and and in the movie you see cyril
actually had an embroidery machine in
his garage and i shot b-roll
of him actually doing embroidery work
with this handle under the under the
desk and i mean it was legit it was the
same model that he used in the 40s
so you see that in the film and then i
see the historical um information the
point is 90
of the garment
industry was owned by jews
and so when they talk about the jewish
boss calling roger into his office and
saying hey did you see the black guy
this morning i was showing him around
the shop
well
he says he doesn't work saturdays he
keeps the jewish sabbath and i want to
know what denomination he works in
he goes to
because he says he's a christian
and roger said so what
because roger comes up from a catholic
background and sunday is he's been
taught as the sabbath and in the
tradition traditional christian uh
concept right
so uh but he said listen i want you to
sit next to cyril on monday because he's
starting on monday i hired him he's
really good
and um
i want you to find out what denomination
look at that little divine orchestration
right there yeah there you go you're
gonna sit next to this guy
so he did a favor for his boss who was a
jew and he could and his boss could not
sleep that's how much the spirit of god
gave him this and and he was a friend of
rogers and they were friends and so
roger sat next to cyril on monday wow
and you'll see um
the outgrowth of that and to to me you
guys the the greatest
joy uh i happen to be a seventh-day
adventist christian
and one of the great joys for me in
working on this was being able to work
with cyril and cynthia
again here's behind the scenes
um
how could anyone know that cynthia
and cyril were about to die they were
almost 90 years old when i interviewed
them for this phone
sharing their testimony cynthia was the
only one who remembered exact montreal
street addresses where they
studied that's impressive yeah she
studied and where roger and cyril were
baptized the exact building she
remembered the address wow cyril had
long forgotten those details
but cyril remembered other things that
she didn't that's cool and so they were
a team
well
i interviewed them in the fall of 2014
and cynthia
suddenly died of a heart attack three
months after that three months wow
isn't that amazing wow i had never met
her she's never seen the the culmination
of this no wow no and cyril got cancer a
year later and died wow cyril gave three
interviews
and um the first interview with the both
of them together
uh again
to me it's people can go oh that's just
like you got lucky that you were able to
interview no they were almost 90. yeah
yeah and by the way i had tried to get a
hold of roger morneau's family for three
years
and no response and i had almost given
up
i literally was getting ready to go back
into the corporate world
and my brother who's a pastor prayed a
heart-moving
cry you know have you ever had someone
pray for you that's so deep in your
heart that you you know they're being
moved by the spirit to pray very deeply
for you
that was the kind of prayer he prayed
and on my way home i was driving from
tennessee to orlando i got a call two
hours later again three years i've been
trying to reach them
wow two hours later roger's daughter
calls me on my cell phone
i pull off the highway onto the shoulder
and we talked for almost an hour wow
and so i just praise the lord because
cynthia and cyril were about to die
yeah and without them we wouldn't have
the kind of
the testimony because when you think
about the evidence that roger really was
a satan worshipper you really see it in
our film for those who are questioning
if there's a real devil
uh cyril finally by the way getting back
to the fact cyril was not a seventh-day
adventist at the time he studied the
bible with roger
whoa
cynthia was but he was not he was a
sunday protestant wow so what i love
about this that's so compelling is that
it's not an infomercial for a
denomination right right it's about the
truth of the scriptures that draws in to
a commitment
to a relationship that's interesting
because he was keeping the sabbath
though or at least was telling the boss
that he wanted it off at least
exactly see he had been convicted and
this is how cyril comes into the story
and you see it in the film developed
you're right why did he say that it's
because he had prayed a prayer just two
weeks before at another factory and he
said lord i know i've i've studied this
sabbath thing with the adventist pastor
i don't agree with it i don't think you
care what day we keep but if you care
give me one person
that i can witness to
that
that's amazing
give me one person sent to him by a
jewish
boss you look at this story and really
the the highlight of the story is roger
right you know in all of this but really
god is working on two people at the same
time yeah it's been
probably more than two people you know
there's all these side stories of people
bumping into each other and and god
answering praise is incredible can we
play the trailer and then i want to tell
you a modern day
uh bridge to our generation in this
story awesome
if i make it back tomorrow night and get
the fifth bible study it'll be a super
miracle from god you make it sound like
it's a matter of life and death
that's exactly what it is
those aren't spirits they're union
workers
there's power in roger's story there's
something that doesn't want me to
continue typing this
this man is connected with the guy above
and you want to talk to her and pray for
i wanted to know what he knew
and why his prayers were so
powerful
so this is going to be played for the
first time on youtube when
on march 20 march 20.
sunday march 20 1 p.m eastern time okay
that is right around the corner and we
will put a link to this uh where people
can get a hold of this um your your
youtube page yeah what is your youtube
page really uh it's it's uh live streams
media or my live streams is the channel
where people can subscribe and get
notified it's also available on amazon
prime right correct it's on amazon prime
it's on 2b it's on roku god has opened
up a lot of doors yeah but with youtube
it was really exciting you guys because
we got to on one channel got to put all
six subtitle languages oh nice
subtitles in german and spanish
portuguese in french in japanese yeah in
english and
to be able to have all these languages
to put on in one place
uh is is just really a blessing that's
really neat no i don't know if you're
gonna bring up the other documentary
beware of angels on this show or another
show are you yeah definitely how much
time do we have
keep going
we got time
all right i want to tell once one quick
story you just saw the trailer
and um one of the things that i wanted
to to say by the way this is a shot
behind the scenes of one of after one of
the interviews this is the real cereal
with the actor cyril
so this is his grandson cyril iii
um cyril grosses holding this book this
bound book uh uh this is the copy that
roger mourinho of his uh conversion
story that became this book wow uh and
it's just it's amazing how how
cyril capped a copy not only of the
whole manuscript for all those years
which finally came out when i started
researching i was reading the whole
thing and i was like the world needs to
see this god and he did open a door
but in addition to that cyril had a copy
of the actual bible study pages that's
so awesome that they used in 1946 that's
so awesome
this is like uh 18 to 20 questions and
on the back there's notes and back in
the 40s people
good bible carrying people would just
grab the first study slide it in their
bible and go off to their bible study
and that was it
well these went out of print in 1950
and you can't get them anywhere wow but
cyril kept them for 70 years wow
and and one night i was like cyril would
you trust me to send um those original
pages i believe that someday the lord's
going to want the whole world to see
the study that saved roger's life wow
and so he mailed them to me that's
really cool i want to show you what
happened the night i was scanning them
i promised you i would show you this
these are the actual pages he mailed to
me uh several years ago and a big bear
came down our street that night oh wow
and what it sat down in a neighbor's
yard and ended up
running across the street and bursting
through oh
this is security camera footage
this bear is huge that truck that he's
walking in front of is six feet wide oh
wow
that was a big bear he came twice he
came at the beginning of my journey in
this film uh the night i was scanning
these bible study pages and five years
later he came through again and broke
through my fence wow wow
this is footage from the top of the roof
of my house one day i was on the phone i
heard a bang the treetop uh broke off
the top of this tree
came down hit my chimney and then landed
on my roof i thought it was going to
come through my roof
this was the week we announced
post-production for charm by darkness
this is a huge oak tree and the whole
top was broken off and slammed down
on the top of my roof and a whole nother
uh a whole nother top of another big oak
tree came off as well
but
the
there's some audio to this now
the day after i drove down and i was
looking for evidence because to see if
anyone else had been damaged and there
was no evidence anywhere in the
neighborhood
this day there was a little pile in the
neighbor's yard across the street from
my house he had just mowed his yard but
this is my driveway yeah
and you'll see as i'm driving up around
this debris
you'll see the top of the tree had
broken off and fallen down and this
was a very targeted attack yeah yeah
very much targeted you could see oh yeah
right up there
behind the house the top that had been
the whole top of the tree ripped off
it's called a micro burst wow
only over your house
and i actually have i was on the phone
and i heard what sounded like a freight
train coming
it's like a tornado it's a mini tornado
that can come out of nowhere
and it came right behind my house and
and you see the pictures for the first
time by the way i've never shown these
publicly
but this is another way that god was
showing me yeah that there there are
some forces that are very very afraid
right of this truth this story reminds
me of the story of job yeah you know you
know
came and destroyed his whole son's house
you know just like that it's not just a
story that happened two generations ago
and one of the other things that god did
while i was working on this
is um
we
i mentioned that we were working with a
publisher to bring out the full
manuscript
one of the things that happened was the
the typed manuscript that cyril sent me
was too old and faded to get good ocr
scans
to create an editable digital document
right
so i had to hire someone to type
from the typed pages oh wow so that we
could get a an editable document to the
publisher and get this out
so what happened was
uh
this this woman amanda was the third
person not the first not the second but
the third person that we hired to do
this project
this is a real person sorry what
happened to the other two well
again this is behind the scenes evidence
that that god that this is true that all
of this is true spiritual
warfare
so the first person agreed to a price
started working on it and had to quit a
week later she had a family emergency
never happened to me before hired him on
a freelancing website didn't know these
people
second person when and you know when you
put out a bid you'll get several people
who give you offers so i went to another
one that had good reviews hired her she
agreed
i never heard from her she just
disappeared within a couple of days wow
and so i went to my knees and i said
lord
this is your story if you want it out
please help us find someone well amanda
this this young woman
was one of the people who had offered to
do the book do you ever hire someone who
has no reviews who's brand new on this
freelancer
pretty rare right
can you imagine that i was desperate by
an arrow
and her note actually said something
like
i read the summary that you sent out
with your proposal and this is material
that looks really interesting to me this
was in her notes
and i was like lord she has no reviews
right i don't know if she's gonna be
able to even type right
so
we hired her sometimes you know it's
like god puts people in your path that
really have a heart for it you know it's
not just somebody doing their job
she's like into it you know right
i want you to know what happened was so
amazing in the trailer you saw her this
this is the actual person and we
reenacted her story
this is this is what happened and you'll
see this in the movie she she started
typing this manuscript
and
she
realized
that this was an answer to one of her
prayers see i learned later wow that she
had started reading the bible on her own
wow and that she had kept a prayer
journal
she would ask god questions that she
didn't understand in the bible she
wondered why the christian world didn't
keep the bible sabbath
and she was writing questions to god in
her prayer journal two weeks before we
hired her wow
and he goes here i got a job for you
just answer your question
while she was typing this she saw this
roger morneau was exposed to the
biblical truth about the biblical
sabbath and she felt the lord go hey
remember your prayer journal
here's your answer
so the first sabbath while she was
working on this
she decided to keep the bible sabbath
wow
and a whole host of things broke loose
that day oh wow
and you see what happened in the movie
what a courageous young woman
she's the bridge wow she's the bridge
wow because
she's sitting in her friend's room
talking about this project she's working
on how she
came to understand about the sabbath
suddenly the light started flickering on
and off in the room for no reason
and then
then the stove in the kitchen starts
sparking it's one of those um
it's clicking
but here's the thing her friend this was
her friend's house her stove hadn't been
working for months
it was unplugged
and you see this in the movie they ran
into the kitchen and they checked under
the cupboards and sure enough it was
unplugged but it's sparking
oh wow
there's more to the story but you'll
have to watch it wow
so so talk about this book for a second
charmed by darkness um we can actually
put a link to where they can get a hold
of a copy of this but we can even do
something better than that we're going
to give one away i'm going to give one
of these away because this is an amazing
story i mean just like you heard right
here i mean just total transformation on
somebody just typing this out you will
be changed by reading this book this is
a powerful book so
definitely get a hold of the copy of
this we'll leave a description in the
link below
so you're going to have a a raffle or
you know what we generally do is we we
put a form on our on our website there's
a link that we put in our
description of our video it's you know
little light studios dot tv slash free
offer
and they'll go to that it'll have the
latest offer which will be this book
they'll fill out the form and it'll be i
use the random number generator awesome
to see how many people
yeah we just send it to whoever wins
that is so so awesome so it sounds like
there's a lot of spiritual warfare going
on trying to get this out
that's so cool you can share those
little details that nobody gets to see
when they watch the movie which isn't
surprising
because of what he went through right
and we've we've kind of talked a lot
around the story without really kind of
linearly talking about his story
and it's an incredible story you know
but basically the short version if you
were to to
recap like what happened to roger like
he was
enticed into a satanic cult
and to to
really not just not just
be a part of it
but really
be at the top very close to the top
because they not only wanted to entice
him to be there but they they reached
out him specifically yeah they told
members of their call reach out to this
guy and be here on a certain day because
we want this guy on our ranks yeah and
so about that same time he meets
cyril and he decides to do
bible studies because he knows what he's
getting into over here kind of he kind
of gets that but he wants to know
what what's on the other side
and so he he decides to do the bible
studies if i remember right he does them
like
in a week's time or something like that
a whole bunch of them you know just
eating them up yeah and then at the
basically at the end of it he decides
i'm going to follow god yeah i'm not
going to i'm not going to follow this
path of darkness over here i'm going to
follow god and all the all the members
of this satanic cult are saying don't
worry we've experienced this before
this guy is going to be
killed he's dead he's dead and
he lived to a ripe old age
for a long time do you remember what his
age was when he died yeah i mean he
relatively older compared to what the
risks were trying to get
he died at 73 from a brain aneurysm yeah
you know i showed this um
to a small group in a in a home setting
around the time we released it and there
was a woman crying
when that part in the movie came out
and she said you know someone someone
spoke over me when i was in my 20s and
prophesied over me that i was going to
die when i turned a certain age
or in my 40s and she said last year i
turned that age
and i was looking over my shoulder all
the time wondering when i was going to
drop
wow
isn't that something and she said i see
that the evil had no power to take roger
out he died from natural
natural causes i mean they didn't shoot
him and you'll see there's a storyline
in there again god sent more witnesses
wow that this that they were harassing
roger until the year that he died yeah
the secret society tried to take him out
when he interviewed on amazing facts
yeah the last year can you tell more
about that story i think that's a
fascinating story yeah i mean there's a
story line in the film so it's developed
and
he had a confidant a young friend
because he didn't want to scare his
family members about this stuff and
the week before
roger went to interview with doug
batchelor he got a phone call and you
know back in the 90s you had landline
phones cell phones were not the
mainstream
and if you had spam calls or people
calling you that you didn't want to call
you could set up a security three-digit
security code that you would then give
out to your family and friends so that
no one else could get a hold of you
well this phone call came from a
stranger and somehow bypassed the
security wow
wow
and this person said i know who you are
and we're going to have someone there
ready to shoot you
and roger told gandhi gandhi is we tell
dondy's story we reenacted dondy's story
and charmed by darkness
he's he's a typical young adult who's
lost and doesn't know doesn't have hope
in christ
and he's seeking he's seeking something
real and he stumbles on to a roger
morneau book
on prayer
on supernatural answers to prayer and he
wants to know how this guy knows how to
pray and how how is it that this man
prays so powerfully and has answers
so he drove seven hours without an
appointment
from from loma linda to modesto
california knocked on roger and hilda's
door
in the early 90s
and they opened the door and invited
this stranger into their office into the
apartment and they became friends and um
and donde i interviewed him in
california for the film and he talks
about how roger confided in him and told
him about this death threat that he
received that roger hadn't told anybody
about again it just adds more
credibility through witnesses yeah that
roger was telling the truth so so maybe
you can kind of uh talk a little bit
about some of the things that he did
witness that was some crazy supernatural
things i remember when i read tripping
to supernatural and seeing the
typewriters typing with nobody sitting
there at them
do you guys you bring up some of those
things in here you know we wrote a
screenplay for
really going into this the experiences
roger talks about in the secret society
the docudrama was really intended to to
illuminate the witnesses
and the documents we could find to show
the rest of the story
to add credence to that part of it
because all we have is what roger wrote
right yeah
but we have some pretty scary stuff in
charm by darkness that shows um in fact
perhaps if we have time i could show
the clip where cyril actually finds out
the devil is a real person mm-hmm
or do we have time to watch it yeah
[Music]
the spirits have been trying to get in
contact with me
they harass me at night
spirits
those aren't spirits they're new young
workers
i know just how to handle those type of
people
let's go
i still was not a believer in the devil
i went to his house and he lived at the
end of a long hall
what time do these union people get here
you call them union people
they come at midnight
now
[Music]
and there was nothing that i could see
there
i told you it's not union workers it's
okay sit down sit down it's fine
i was afraid and i sat down in the chair
and writers said don't worry as long as
i don't talk to them they cannot
communicate with me i didn't think it
was going to happen like this he said
don't be nervous
a knock came to his balcony door and it
was so strong that it almost knocked the
wall down
i'm doing two things man
i'm getting rid of this gun
and imma get baptized to sabbath
i gotta go
have a good night
[Music]
so nonchalant about this he's like yeah
this happens all the time
you know i think it's probably because
he had so much evidence on both sides of
that fence that he was just like
completely confident you know what i
mean like like hey i know god's more
powerful than this amen
and i wonder i wonder what that would do
to all of our faith i think that's kind
of the neat thing about reading this
story
is it kind of gives you a little peek
into theirs but really the power of the
story is god is much stronger than any
of this darkness that's right
what's fascinating i didn't know
that he was more or less harassed
his wife no i didn't know that i thought
it was kind of like once he made it out
of that experience it's kind of like
yeah he was a prayer warrior happy
happily ever after
i didn't realize it was just like it
kept coming back and he still had death
threats and you know all these
we
i was so privileged to be able to get to
be very close to roger's daughter and
son-in-law and grandson michael who are
all interviewed in the film
and they all talk about some of these
ongoing harassments that happened
uh that they witnessed yeah they were
you know even in their in their years
later in roger's life wow so you're
right scotty getting back to your
comment
the book isn't glorifying satan you know
some people
who are christian are so afraid to talk
about satan
but there is a great battle going on and
this is why i believe roger's story is
so compelling
even today two generations later and you
heard from amanda who typed this book
who's only in her 30s all the similar
stuff started happening to her
harassments unseen
she even saw shadow people following her
on the way home i had to google them
yeah never heard of it before yeah these
are apparitions dark apparitions that
are fallen angels who are manifesting my
daughter who's 11 years old actually
said she's seen them before when she was
i don't know four or five and she was
talking in her room and i went in there
and i said who are you talking to and
she was the shadow people i said don't
ever talk to shadow people i said don't
no matter what they say don't ever and
she's just like okay never heard about
it again after that but wasn't that
portrayed in the movie
ghost
with patrick swayze and demi moore i
remember it's been a long time since
i've seen that movie but they talked
about shadow i've seen shadow people
they didn't talk about shadow people but
there were
uh characters that were
shadows that would try to pull
people into the shadows or they would
you know you could you notice they were
going places there was no physical body
or anything but there was shadows
of beings and they would
think of peter pan but the only power
the only power that the fallen angels
have and lucifer himself is whatever we
give him are the lies of deception if he
can get you to believe a lie
and his his best
and that's
actually we're going to get to beware of
angels but the next film we're going to
talk about how he's packaged a lot of
truth with with with with lies
and he's getting away with it in the
christian church today yeah but but i
i'm so glad that you brought that up
this is not a glorifying of darkness
it's it's the invitation and the
curiosity that the devil packages stuff
that makes it look like great
entertainment and you guys are so good
at explaining to young people
about this nice packaging
but roger didn't stay there he was
charmed
but he made a decision to come out when
he saw the truth that set him free
a lot of people get involved in the
dark sides of the entertainment industry
because they believe that they'll have
more power or prestige or whatever and
it's very interesting i think there's
enough evidence today that people won't
deny that very easily that that goes on
i mean there's there's people doing
these ritualistic things out in the open
but to to really hear about this
happening in the 40s and you know at a
time that you know just just you didn't
hear about that and and and uh you know
this is this is neat to see his journey
coming out of this and really getting
more charmed by jesus amen and i think
that's a neat story that's what it's
about in the end
uh mikey you asked about beware of
angels i have a clip that i brought
and it's
it's another behind-the-scenes testimony
of what god did while i was working on
this other related film to rogers legacy
roger's last book was titled beware of
angels
there was a true story of a bible study
group in grants pass oregon
in the 1980s where
where two sisters ended up murdering
some close friends family friends in
this bible study group
and it became national news and this
woman sharon halstead has been convicted
for 75 years she's in a prison in oregon
for the rest of her life
very sad i wasn't going to touch it with
a 10-foot pole
somebody sent me the book in the mail i
wasn't asking for it
it ended up being a second documentary
well now there's a third but
this was the second one that came out as
it related to
all of the ways that satan packages his
deceptions he christianizes them he's
got them in the occult he's got them in
the new age and you see
different ways different faces of this
original lie you will not surely die
yeah
and so i want to show you a clip of my
time in oregon some clips from what i
saw in the murder evidence because i got
to go twice to the grants pass police
department
but you'll hear a voice at the end of
this clip of an elderly man you won't
see his face until you watch the movie
but he's the father of the victims whose
daughter was murdered
and it was a miracle that he came and
gave an interview in my hotel room
you should know that no one they had
never given an interview for over 30
years after this murder
and less than two months after this
movie came out suddenly oprah's oxygen
network discovery channel
another national network wanted to come
to grant's pass and interview all these
people
it was just so fascinating that god let
us do ours first and then suddenly here
comes hollywood they want to suddenly
but they were diving into the murder
itself and we were looking for the
spiritual side of it
um and and you'll see when you see the
movie how it ties into the the
immortality of the soul deception
[Music]
they asked me why i wanted to go there
i said because i want to know the truth
it's a bizarre tale that could offer
sobering warnings to our generation
uh
sharon halstead killed long longtime
friend lynn green
and also shot lynn's husband david and
their three-year-old boy nathaniel
but why
in short
an angel made me do it
our research included court documents
newspaper coverage and 10 boxes of
evidence at the grants pass police
department
in addition to evidence of the crimes
the boxes included spiral notebooks and
hundreds of pieces of paper revealing
the group's fascination and obsession
with angels
over a five-year period the group
documented interactions with 160
angels who made promises and won their
confidence and love
you here in this room know more the
future than any man woman or child in
this world
what happens within this house must not
reach any man's ears
god is secret
and this all
in spite of the fact that they were
reading the scriptures and so forth i
have no idea what the
bible studies were about or anything
like that but that was
a way in for them
wow that's crazy
so so a real quick synopsis
these
these two sisters were in communication
with angels or the whole group was
the whole group was yes so in the bible
study these angels were showing up and
discussing things with them so the the
group started praying
and asking god hey listen god you let
angels appear in bible times since it's
the last days and we're sabbath keepers
they basically demanded that god should
give them permission to have open
communication with angels
and sure enough three months later one
of the people in the group she was the
one who ended up getting murdered by the
way
she was the one who started getting
channeled messages from
the angelic coast who claimed to be from
the courts of heaven wow and some of the
rest of them started seeing these
manifestations at one point they even
saw jesus what they believed was jesus
appearing giving personal messages you
see that in the film
they said that he he jesus got is taller
than the house before he disappeared
you know he appeared in their living
room and then just gradually grew until
he was taller he went through the roof
um
it was signs and wonders see
that's that and one of them started
david green jr whose wife was murdered
he was shot in the back their son a
three-year-old boy was shot in the face
you saw that in this little clip no wow
shot in the face and he
lived
and he's now a quadriplegic wow
but it's just horrible
the i i agreed for three days when i
read this book that roger morneau had
written a year before he died wow roger
didn't want to write this book by the
way the viewers uh if you're interested
come and see a brand new video on our
live streams media youtube channel where
roger's talking about how he didn't want
to write this book
and god made it so clear and he talks
about on this video how it was that god
started giving him dreams every night
and the same dream started hitting him
three nights in a row and finally he he
knew the lord was letting him know he
had to write this book and so he went up
to the prison in oregon from california
and spent three days with these sisters
in prison wow
now since then one of the sisters has
been released from prison uh she made
parole and got released uh because she
she worked with the government and
basically became an estate's witness and
they gave her a lower sentence
but sharon halstead still believe still
blames
the fallen angels for the mistake
that she was drawn into but here's the
point and i was sharing this with brad
before we filmed it today
the the the whole point of this film i
saw the lord was leading was that these
sisters murdered someone in their group
because they came to believe in the dual
nature of man
this angel naked truth was the name this
angel was coming and sending messages
started telling them that certain people
were totaled yeah so
the angel would say the key
is totaled and that meant that his
spirit had been removed and a demon was
now inhabiting his physical body oh wow
wow that's how it she believed that
so she was told that lynn and david and
their boy were all totaled oh wow and
they didn't want to do it
but then the angel naked truth
threatened to total her and her sister
if they didn't do it
does that sound like angels from heaven
to you
right wow satan is so deceiving when i
remember when i watched that i was just
mind blown because i was like okay why
would these girls do this and then the
angel is saying look if you don't do it
you're going to be destroyed because
you're not doing what god's asking you
to do he wants to use you as an
instrument now we say that angels
wouldn't do that but think about like
when god told them hey you're going to
make the walls of jericho fall down or
you're going to go in there and take
that city right they gave them christmas
so deceptive you know like
and that's why it's just so important to
to stay in the word
and and these girls i believe had a
um a desire to do a true desire to know
more to get close to god and all that
and then this thing happens
and what you were talking about earlier
i was going to say something about it
about
the people who sell their souls for fame
and fortune and stuff
jesus never promised anyone fame and
fortune but satan was the one that said
i'll give you all the kingdoms of the
world if you bow down and so people are
doing that to this day and how did jesus
respond
it is written it is written it is
written he is a spiritual foe we cannot
do anything to him except use the sword
and his whole
his whole uh
battle against us is to keep us
distracted from being in there yeah he
doesn't have trouble yeah he doesn't
have to keep you in the occult or
whatever if he can keep you playing
bejeweled all day and keep you out of
that word then he's won
i want to make one very important point
for our viewers and that is this murder
didn't happen overnight right yeah
five years
this bible study these angels when they
started believe me they weren't talking
about being total right if they would
have started that way
that bible study group would have known
where they were yeah
but they first had to gain their trust
and so these angels were giving these
beautiful scriptural you know the devil
quoted scripture to jesus
right
so over the course of time they were led
down this road until one of their group
was doing out-of-body experiences he
would center down and meditate and he
would he would fly off to what he
believed was the new jerusalem
and someone else in the group had
another spiritual gift as they believed
they were being given these but it was
nothing more than a christianized
version of the occult yeah and you you
know we're talking about knowing our
scriptures but you know
this is something that has been a very
sobering reminder to me
the devil knows the bible right more
right than any human being alive what's
the difference he fears the weakest
saint you know why
because
they have the holy spirit of god
see the devil might know a lot of stuff
but he sees everything through a
distortion
that bear that came into my
neighborhood by the way i had never seen
a a bear on my street in florida many
years
and it's orlando it's all around the
country right
the devil can't help himself yeah he
came and and that god knows the devil's
just gonna go and he's gonna show his
eventually he's gonna show and he
actually helped to prove that the story
is true
and and so he sees everything through a
distortion and we also
can know a lot about this
amazing book
but without the holy spirit that's right
it doesn't make the proper sense we're
going to misinterpret it yep
my cousin deborah who's been on this
show a couple times she actually visited
a
like a bible study barn or something and
all these people out there and she said
she started seeing some weird stuff she
didn't see weird stuff she saw that the
people were all about like oh have you
seen an angel yet and she's like no oh
we all see angels out here and stuff and
then she said one time she was there i
don't know if she went more than once or
whatever but
they were all doing the bible study and
there's a little boy just sitting there
and he goes i see jesus and she's like
i'm out of here
so
a little little known fact of history
modern day spiritualism
but we would credit to modern day
spiritualism started in the 1700s with a
man named emmanuel swedenborg and when
he was in his 50s he started
communicating on a regular basis
with an angel
and that's where he got his information
and his writings are what influenced
people in the 1800s because he was
probably the most educated man in europe
so when he was writing it was more
readily available and people were
soaking up the ideas and the bible talks
about satan transformed as an angel of
light so
i'm really impressed with that
documentary i've watched it multiple
times with friends on amazon prime is
that the only place you can find it yeah
you can find it now on youtube for free
all right
thank you for bringing that up that was
really nice we'll see you know it's
available on you know 2b you can watch
it on 2b and on amazon prime but you
know amazon changed their whole thing
now now you can't stream document most
documentaries no longer are free to
stream with amazon prime membership
so i'm just i'm thankful to the lord
that now by the way uh beware of angels
is available with subtitles in four
languages
german spanish portuguese and english so
for those of you who have family members
in those countries um we're now you know
such a melting pot of different cultures
i'm just thankful we have one place now
a global link to share it with people
that's awesome well chris you are so
interesting you gotta come back
i'd love to
actually you're gonna come back next
week
so we're glad to just get a scratching
of the surface here and thank you so
much for your work in this field i i
understand uh let me give you a little
sneak peek of the next week that we're
gonna talk with him um you weren't
always a filmmaker that's right so we're
gonna talk a little bit about that we're
gonna get like how he even got involved
in this work in the first place because
i think it's a it's by god's direction
that you even started working on these
projects and so thank you for blessing
us do you have a patreon or anything if
people want to support what you do
not yet not yet okay pay for this man we
are we are a not-for-profit organization
you can donate on our website at
lifestreams.org
if you if you feel impressed to support
awesome we will put a link on the
description below if you'd like to
communicate with chris other than that
thank you so much for blessing us with
your time thank you and uh i look
forward to hearing how you really got
into this and some more but definitely
march 20 you guys
check this out it will be streamed the
documentary charmed by darkness on
youtube march 20 we'll put the link in
the description below and uh look
forward to that thanks scotty watch
party with your friends that's right
[Music]
[Applause]
you